[Music]
once upon a time our favorite Disney
Princesses belong to very different
fairy tales we're about to pull their
surprising stories out from under the
rug did you know that beast and Belle's
love story was actually based on a
real-life couple
keep watching to get the full story take
it with you so you'll always have a way
to look back Princess Rapunzel
Rapunzel's story dates back to the 17th
century but the folk tale is centuries
older than that it all started when
Rapunzel's mother was pregnant with her
and she began having cravings for an
herb that her daughter would later be
named after Rapunzel's father was caught
stealing the plant from a witch's garden
and agreed to give up his unborn child
as penance consequently Rapunzel was
locked up and raised in a doorless tower
one day a prince stumbled across the
tower and climbed up unannounced he fell
in love with Rapunzel who soon felt
pregnant when her pregnancy became
obvious the witch abandoned her in the
desert one night the Prince returned to
the tower to find an ugly witch instead
of his beautiful bride-to-be you want me
to be the bad guy he flung himself from
the tower in disgust blinding himself in
the process and if that wasn't bad
enough he went on to roam the desert for
seven years before crossing paths with
Rapunzel again who had given birth to a
set of twins all on her own
Rapunzel's tears of joy cured the
princes blindness and they returned to
his kingdom to live happily ever after
chief mallanna unlike rapunzel Moana was
purely invented by Disney the story of
demigod Maui on the other hand is a very
popular one amongst Pacific Islanders
Disney chose to simplify his backstory
by making him an orphan yeah I took one
look but Maui originally came from the
big and complex family the Maui myths
are a part of Maui mythology which
follows the Maui brothers and their many
accomplishments Disney paid homage to
the Maui Polynesian myths by
adding some of the gods victories into
his lyrics now he was known for using
his fishhook to pull up islands from the
Pacific Ocean we too said to have formed
the polynesian islands although Moana
story starts and ends with Disney Maui's
is centuries-old Princess Anna and Queen
Elsa the frozen sisters story is loosely
based on the Hans Christian Andersen's
fairy tale The Snow Queen however
they're far from being sisters in their
original tales the story's protagonists
are Gerda and Kai who are two childhood
friends when Kai gets kidnapped by The
Snow Queen Gerda goes on a terrifying
and challenging quest in hopes of
bringing him back home problem is the
snow Queens kiss has frozen Kai's heart
wiped his memory and turned him into a
devoted follower Gerda risks her life to
save her friend showing true love in the
process
Goethe's love is enough to save Kai in
the end yeah we can totally see where
Disney drew their inspiration from
Princess Mulan unlike the other Disney
Princesses Mulan is believed to have
been a real-life person who lived during
the northern and southern dynasties wha
Mulan story was passed down from
generation to generation through The
Ballad of Mulan this old ballad told
tales of Milan's bravery and victory
Mulan story has been retold throughout
Chinese history there have been many
adaptations and plays before thinner
honor but the original story is very
different than the Disney movie we all
know and love
when Mulan finds out that the men in her
family must defend China she volunteers
to take her father's place
her parents give her their blessing and
Mulan leads to fight for 12 full years
unlike Disney's Mulan whoa ahhh maaan
already knew how to fight and was gifted
in martial arts sword fighting and
archery it said that no one realized she
was a woman until the war was over
that's when her fellow soldiers first
saw her wearing traditional female
Chinese clothing Princess Ariel Disney's
The Little Mermaid and Hans Christian
Andersen's 19th century fairy tale but
the same name have a lot in common well
except for a happy ending of course both
stories start with young gorgeous
mermaids who visit the surface they both
saved the prince from drowning and fall
in love with him wanting nothing more
than to marry their love
the mermaids visit a sea witch to strike
a deal and here's where their stories
start to differ in Ariel's original
story she gives the sea which her voice
and tongue in exchange for human lace
but there's a catch walking on her new
legs is agonizing
if Ariel succeeds in getting the prince
to marry her she'll be granted a human
soul but if she fails her heart will
break
and she'll dissolve into sea foam
unfortunately for the little mermaid the
Prince marries a neighboring princess
who he believes to have saved him from
the shipwreck the mermaids sisters
strike a deal with the sea witch to save
her life
if the mermaid succeeds in murdering the
prince with a special knife and placing
a drop of blood on her feet she will
live understandably the little mermaid
is unable to carry out this task and
dissolves into seafoam princess Belle we
weren't kidding around when we said that
Belle and beasts love story was the real
deal Disney's the Beauty and the Beast
was inspired by real-life events that
occurred in France during the 16th
century I never felt this way about
anyone I want to do something for her
the fairy tale was written by French
author Gabrielle Suzanne Barbeau de
Villanueva she drew inspiration from
Petra's Gonsalves and his bride-to-be
Katherine's very peculiar romance Petra
suffered from a condition called
hypertrichosis which caused him to grow
thick hair all over his body and face it
made him look like a total beast and he
was treated as such by the town spoke
Katherine and Petrus got married and had
seven children and managed to live out
their version of a happily ever after so
there you guys have it the real stories
behind our favorite Disney Princess
movies tell us which Disney Princesses
you want us to cover next in the comment
section below thanks for watching the
things don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to our channel for more
fun content we'll catch you next time
[Music]